c'est par un café que commence toujours
les rendez vous avec les proches les
collaborateurs comme loïc qui accompagne
michel raison depuis plus de 20 ans oui
monsieur qui devient souhaiterait mois
d'octobre mais il faut lui expliquer que
juste avant de refermer définitivement
l'agenda réouvre on le livre politique
du michel raison
l'histoire débute en 1998 avec un
premier chapitre au conseil régional
puis un second à la mairie de luxeuil et
puis un troisième à l'assemblée
nationale et puis enfin un dernier au
sénat ce qui me caractérise ray le plus
d'être resté moi-même en permanence et
pas vouloir rentrer dans le jeu
j'appellerai pas sales mensonges mais de
l'ada transformation excessive de la
vérité soit par excès de diplomatie soit
par excès de démagogie mais j'ai
toujours refusé sauf depuis 90 il n'a
pas changé sa formule préférée c'est de
dire que
il avait promis de pas prendre la grosse
tête il l'a vraiment pas prise sur les
murs de sa permanence à
luxeuil-les-bains des souvenirs de toute
cette ville y en a eu des joyeux
d'autres moins pour lui l'amoureux de la
terre le paysan dans l'âme qui s'est
lancé dans ce combat politique en
prenant des cons parfois également un
très mauvais souvenir d'une affaire
qu'avait été monté de toutes pièces par
un syndicat opposé aux miens et par le
parti socialiste aussi sur une reprise
de ferme de mon fils quelque chose de
complètement farfelu qu'on était devenu
une affaire nationale ça c'est les plus
mauvais souvenir que j'ai souffert le
père aimant les souffrances il faut
savoir les acceptant silence c'est le
jeu de la politique se relever continuer
le combat michel raison qui aura 71 ans
le 5 novembre montrent une dernière fois
sur le ring
direction paris le sénat la grande
maison en voiture en respectant le 80 km
heure souvenez-vous l'un de ses combats
les plus médiatiques
quelques heures plus tard nous
retrouvons monsieur le sénateur raison
dans l'hémicycle à la place qu'il a
occupée pendant plus de six ans dans
cette haute assemblée qui a vu passer
d'illustrés personnages comme victor
hugo on dit souvent que le sénat c'est
la sagesse le bons sens et peut-être une
bonne conviction pour être bien entendu
j'avais vu un compliment de la part d'un
ministre
quand j'étais député une fois qu'il me
disait toi tu est dangereux parce que
quand tu présenter un amendement tes
collègues ont tendance à voter pour même
quand tu n'es pas d'accord et c'est vrai
que j'ai j'arrivais à faire passer
parfois des choses il ya c'est tout un
ensemble la pédagogie au moment de la
présentation de l'amendement
mais les liens que vous tissez avec vos
collègues tout au cours d
et mois et des années que vous
travaillez avec eux la force du sénateur
raison c'est peut-être d'avoir été
député ce qui lui donne une maîtrise des
institutions qu'ils aiment partager à
son niveau il aura fait évoluer la
société dans le domaine de l'agriculture
de l'agroalimentaire
il aura provoqué les débats des
réflexions gérard larcher le président
du sénat l'a bien apprécié chez son ami
nous fait une journée de salon de
l'agriculture on l'a fait pendant six
ans avec michel raison et vous vous en
souvenez c'est une journée
extraordinaire parce que à la fois ils
vous donnent des clés compréhension et
cette dimension de convivialité c'est
pas simplement se faire plaisir partagé
c'est aussi mieux comprendre la vie des
hommes et des femmes
une page qui se tourne nous tourner de
revoir n'est pas d'adieu michèle raison
l'adil se consacrera sa famille
maintenant mais il continuera d'apporter
son expérience une autre forme
d'engagement politique ou pas réponse
dans les prochains mois